continuing the exploration of deities
from Celtic and Irish mythology today
we'll be taking a look at Bridget a
goddess that is commonly associated with
fertility poetry healing Smith crafts
and the season of spring over the years
the goddess went by several names
including Bridget Bridget bridge and
Bragan Shia with her name roughly
translated to mean the exalted one of
the high Wan she does make an appearance
in Irish mythology as a member of the
Tour de Danone the daughter of the Dagda
and the wife of Bres a half form Orion
who once assumed the role of King much
like the Morrigan she was also seen as a
triple goddess being described as the
goddess of poetry with two sisters
sharing the same name Brigid the healer
and Brigid the Smith
she was also thought to be closely
associated with Saint Brigid but not
only shares many of her attributes but
her feast will take place on the 1st of
February the same date as the pagan
festival of amok that would mark the
start of spring this in turn led to many
arguing that Saint Brigid was in fact a
Christianized version of the Irish and
Celtic deity now it became quite common
for Irish and Celtic deities to be
demonized and to be somewhat erased from
existence
when Island and large portions of Europe
became Christianized but this transition
from goddess this ain't allowed Brigid
to survive at a time when any spiritual
belief for the worship of any other gods
outside of Christianity was no longer
being tolerated by European countries
the exact influences of Brigid are
fairly unknown but there has been the
suggestion that she may have been
inspired by an indo-european goddess of
dawn this theory is somewhat further
supported by the goddesses ancient
Gaelic name Brio CJD
men in fiery power indicated to us that
she may have also been a goddess of the
Sun she was often depicted with rays of
light and fire emitting from her hair in
her head showing us that she was the
embodiment of the element of fire Brigid
been a triple goddess may have
contributed the amount of things that
she was considered to be patron of
through her tires were fire in the Sun
she was considered to be the goddess of
Smith crafts the healing arts fertility
poetry music
prophecy and
culture with her name also translated to
mean the high one
she was perceived to be the patron of
relatively high dimensions high rising
flame Highlands and concepts and
activities that elevated oneself
psychologically and physically such as
wisdom high intelligence and druidic
knowledge her association moved the
hearth and the home makes her somewhat
comparable to the goddess Hestia in
greek mythology and this association
continued when she became Saint Brigid
as she was often seen as a motherly
figure the worship of Brigid was fairly
widespread amongst the Celtic people of
Island and stretched the highlands of
Scotland and Western Europe the goddess
performed a vital role unifying warring
clans and providing them with a common
bond many saw bridgid as the fire within
their own heart and the fires of
inspiration playing quite an important
part in the everyday life completely
erasing the goddess from existence was
seen to be a poor decision by the
Catholic Church and so they created a
version of Brigid that they could
integrate into the Catholic religion and
thus the story of Saint Brigid of Kaldur
was started a young woman born into a
pagan family around 450 ad through the
help of st. Patrick she was converted to
Christianity and she was best known for
her generosity compassion and charitable
nature given everything she owned the
way to the poor exploring the story of
Bridget is something that I rather
enjoyed she doesn't have an epic history
full of battle adventure but she's still
a very interesting figure it's fairly
surprising to see the amount of areas
that she was considered the patron of
areas such as craftsmanship and
blacksmithing that commonly would not be
associated to a female figure the
worship of most Celtic and Irish deities
became branded as pagan practice but the
role that Brigid performed was
considered so vital that the Catholic
Church had no other choice but to
integrate her into their religion as a
saint I'd love to hear what you guys
think of Brigid were you familiar with
the transition made from goddess to
Saint do those of you following Wicca
have a different outlook on the goddess
or was some of you just not aware that
she existed let me know in the comments
below as always I've been your host
mythology and fiction explained